this is a message from the collective  are you overly tired or experiencing  increased sensitivity remember physical  contact or displays of feeling or danger  to all of us let's do our part to help  contain this disease did anybody see  that anyone recognize him that's her  first jumper in a while  I'm watching you the way you look at the  world the way experiencing stir it's has  to stop if it continues I'll be forced  to report you  I can't stay away I can't not be around  you you realize what would happen if you  do not risk your job do not risk your  life all I need to remember how it was  to feel alive  I was told to keep an eye on you is  there something you want to tell me you  know what are we gonna do  seriously considering this if we stay  here we'll be found out if you make this  decision there's no turning back  I need to remember how to feel alive  before what this feels like  everyone in the city gets a shot at  being a store live on my stage